of all the polarizing issues in politics
today and yes,
there are many.
The climate change debate is right at
the top of the list.
Climate change seems to be one of the
year either with us or you're against
us.
Topics usually debated by people
immediately taking a partisan stance
rather than a well thought out position.
This past year,
I actually lost a good friend who told
me that she could no longer be
associated with people who leave in
debate climate change,
and I'm someone who's had such
conversations on this very show.
I think the most hate that I ever got
for a Reuben report episode was when I
had Alex Epstein,
author of the moral case for fossil
fuels in for a sit down.
Alex.
His argument isn't against manmade
climate change specifically.
Instead,
he's more focused on how to increase
human prosperity with what we have now.
Essentially,
his argument is although climate change
could be real,
fossil fuels still have many net
benefits for our society.
After endless tweets,
emails and messages from angry people.
Alex did a follow up video on youtube
himself where he answered around a
hundred viewer questions.
Engaging with people who have different
views is exactly what the battle of
ideas is all about.
On the flip side of the debate,
I've also sat down with Michael Mann,
a climatologist and the author of the
famous,
the hockey stick and the climate wars,
who's a thought leader in the climate
change debate.
I've discussed climate change to some
degree or another with believers in
manmade climate change like Sam Harris,
Michael Shermer,
and Richard Dawkins,
as well as some of the more skeptical
views such as Andrew Klavan,
Steven crowder,
and Ben Shapiro,
and for the record,
not one of these guests believe the
exact same thing as anyone else I just
mentioned right there.
I find the climate change to be a really
interesting discussion because it often
shows how one's thinking works in other
areas as well.
Generally speaking,
Democrats are those on the left.
See climate change as manmade and
believe that governmental action is the
best or in some cases the only way to
reverse its negative effects.
Republican's are those on the right
generally believe that something is
happening to the environment.
Though there is some debate as to
whether it's manmade but regardless
believed that the private sector is
better left to deal with these issues.
Of course there are outliers on each
side such as my former guests,
California democratic gubernatorial
candidate,
Mike Shellenberger who wants the private
sector to be more involved in solving
climate issues and at the same time
there are also Republicans and people on
the right who deny manmade climate
change at all.
The science debate on climate change is
an interesting one and one in which I'm
happy to have.
What interests me more though is how the
government should or should not be part
of the solution to whatever the problem
may be.
You know,
my feelings on this that the government
is rarely the solution to anything.
Actually at this point,
I think the government is usually the
problem in the first place and I'd
always rather exhaust private options
before turning to the government,
especially the federal government.
Ironically,
this should be the position of the
people who hate trump.
Would you want to keep giving the
government more power when you hate the
guy in charge,
but at the end of the day it's not
governmental power that they have a
problem with.
It's that they only have a problem with
governmental power when it's not their
guy in charge.
Fortunately there does seem to be a
younger generation that is tackling
issues like climate change in the
environment in a totally new way.
It seems to be based not only in
scientific facts but also in an
understanding of how a limited
government should work.
My guest this week is Benji backer,
president of the American conservation
coalition.
The group is dedicated to finding new
ways to look at old problems as its
mantra states.
They are committed to efficient,
effective,
conservative environmentalism.
As for me,
I'm a believer in the science behind
climate change and the funny thing about
science is that it doesn't care whether
you believe in it or not.
For me,
the real debate around climate change is
how to go about finding solutions
without giving more power and more money
to the government.
Whether you believe in climate science
or not,
whether you want more government
regulation or less,
or whether you believe the private
sector can find a solution or not.
We're all stuck on this little rock
together.
So until Elon Musk,
a private businessman gets us all to
Mars.
Let's try to figure out how to solve
some our problems on this pale blue dot.
While we still have a chance.
Okay.
Joining me today is the founder of the
American Conservation Coalition,
an organization committed to efficient,
effective conservative environmental
ism.
Hashtag Green Gop Benji backer,
welcome to the Rubin report.
It's great to be here.
I feel you are long overdue even though
20 years old,
you didn't have a lot of time to get
here,
but you got here.
We've met a couple times.
I kind of found out about you a couple
of years ago.
Uh,
we're going to talk about what kind of
put you on the map in the political
world and got your activism going and
all that.
Uh,
but it's good to have you here.
I liked that you,
uh,
you dressed ready for the park?
Oh yeah.
You gotta you gotta look good to feel
good.
All right,
so you have a really interesting story,
uh,
of what got you in this mix.
But first I just thought I'd like to ask
me,
I guess just kind of tell me a little
bit about your upbringing,
family,
that kind of thing.
Yeah.
So I grew up in a family of five,
a completely non political,
uh,
very close family.
We traveled a lot together.
Uh,
youngest.
I had two older sisters.
Uh,
my parents were actually entrepreneurs.
They started a business when I was,
I want to say 10,
um,
which was a software company based on
mortgages.
And,
uh,
it really started to take off,
but it was during the recession and it
was a really bold move for that time.
I hadn't really paid off and they're not
retired and kind of live the American
dream,
which is a really cool thing to be
brought up by.
Yeah.
What about the politics at home where
you guys always kind of conservative or
didn't talk about it?
Yeah,
actually you've got really differing
views.
My sister is a liberal,
uh,
one of them and then one of them is
more,
uh,
just not into it very much.
Uh,
my parents are conservative,
but they never told us really about
their views.
They wanted us to decide for ourselves,
obviously their morals and values,
I think played into how I feel about
things,
but it was never forced upon us or they
were not adamant about politics or
volunteered or donated to my knowledge,
uh,
to campaigns.
So I really wasn't talked about in the
house.
You know,
they'd have the debates on or they'd,
um,
you'd have the news on,
but nothing really more than that.
So I was able to figure out my opinions
for myself when I was a little bit
earlier than most people when I was 10.
Um,
but yeah,
what kind of opinions does a 10 year old
have?
While I was watching the John Mccain
Obama debates,
which 10 years old,
yes,
at 10 years old.
And I found it really interesting and I
wanted to figure out where I stood on
the spectrum of what I support John
Mccain or would I support,
uh,
I think Senator Obama at the time.
And so I looked up online,
kind of just a basic outline of what
each side believed in and I figured out
that I was conservative.
Um,
and so for the last couple of years I
kind of,
I forced my parents to put signs in our
yard for John Mccain.
I forced them to put bumper stickers on
our cars.
I've [inaudible] what did your parents
think about this?
They're tenured.
They're like,
all right,
we'll support you in whatever you do.
Um,
but they were very,
I mean it's,
it's,
I think that they were surprised.
I mean,
I don't know.
I don't know if any parent thinks that
there are 10 year old kid is going to
get super interested in politics because
it doesn't really affect you at 10 years
old.
It doesn't really affect you until after
college.
Really.
Um,
so that was kind of a surprise to them,
but they were supportive.
They let me,
you know,
research as much as I wanted to and
again,
uh,
they allowed me to put the signs in the
yard,
uh,
the bumper stickers on my ripstik,
you know,
that type of thing.
So it was a pretty cool time.
And then I got injured,
um,
and decided to volunteer because I
couldn't play sports.
So I want to get to that in a sec.
But wait,
I just want a picture of this 10 years
old.
We were watching it,
but I assume you were watching with your
folks probably.
Right.
Okay.
You go online to figure out the issues.
What mattered to you at 10 years old
that you said at the end of it,
okay,
I'm a conservative or I'm going to vote
for Mccain.
Well,
my pa,
my parents were always really fiscally
conservative was just how they spent
money.
You know,
we were never like in a really,
really tough position when I was super
young,
but we always were saying,
you know,
buy the cheapest product you can save as
much money as you can.
And that was something that I was
brought up with.
So that really mattered to me.
And knowing that the government could
take away my parents hard earned money
and knowing that the government could
come in and harm my dad's business by
putting a ton of restrictions,
that kind of struck me pretty harshly.
And then also my family,
we were raised on family values,
right?
You know,
close knit family.
Um,
it kind of happens that way.
So those two things were kind of the
main drivers I would say.
Yeah,
it's just hard to imagine a 10 year old
thing,
but it's pretty cool
and it explains why you're here right
now.
So,
okay,
we'll put you on the map.
And when I found out about you and I
think nationally when people found out
about you and now this makes sense now
that I know that this was brewing at 10
years ago,
2013 you're 15 years old.
Yeah.
What happens?
Yeah,
so I had been active in politics for
three years before that.
And what does that even mean?
Volunteering on Scott Walker's campaign,
Senator Ron Johnson's campaign,
I helped out a Mitt Romney as well in
2012 and
believe it,
sorry to draw up a could people even
believe it?
Like here's this 12 year old kid,
11 year old kid working on these
cameras.
It's actually really funny.
The first campaign ever worked on did
let me use the phones at first because
they can,
when you're talking to a 12 year old on
the phone,
you can tell it's like,
hi is Michael?
And they're like,
uh,
yeah,
but like who are you and why are you 12
and why are you calling me from
congressional office?
Right.
Regressional campaign.
And so people were actually really
surprised.
Conservatives were really supportive.
They're like,
Whoa,
look at this 12 year old kid is
volunteering for us.
And on the left is like,
why is this 12 year old kid volunteering
for them?
Right.
So it was pretty funny.
Now again,
I was injured so I needed something to
do.
And like any 12 year old,
I decided to volunteer for politics.
Um,
very normal.
so yeah,
it was a very interesting dynamic
because this is also hilarious that an
injury got you into politics.
What were,
what kind of injury?
Oh,
it was an ankle injury that the doctors
couldn't figure out.
I was on crutches for a year and a half.
Wow.
Uh,
gained a lot of weight.
Um,
it was during middle school,
which does not help because those were
the worst years for that.
Anyways.
Um,
and so then again,
I went into congressional office and
they didn't want me to do the phones.
They didn't want me to go door to door.
Cause imagine a 12 year old coming to
your door and they're like,
hey,
you should vote for x,
Y or Z.
Right.
Like,
why am I,
why should I trust the 12 year old?
Right.
So,
uh,
this is a very interesting dynamic at
that age.
So,
all right,
so now what puts you on the map?
2013,
you're 15 years old.
Something happened.
Yes.
So,
uh,
in high school,
early on in high school and middle
school teachers had really come after me
for my political views because I was
trying to make local headlines for my
activism,
especially in the recall election,
uh,
for Scott Walker in 2012.
Um,
so
tell me,
tell me a little bit about what your
opinions were in what your teacher,
yeah.
Yeah.
So I was really pro Scott Walker guy.
I was,
I actually ended up becoming close with
his family and then,
and a great guy,
but I even better policies,
um,
you know,
I talked to a lot of teachers who were
sick of being forced to join unions and
sake of starting out with $30,000
base pay when senior senior teachers
were making $100,000
with benefits.
And it took them 40 years to get to that
level,
even if they a better teacher.
Um,
so people were really kind of sick of
that.
Um,
but it was a very small minority because
the unions really had a lot of
brainwashing in the state and I'm sure
in other states as well.
Um,
and so my view is that Scott Walker was
really helping out the state cause he
balance the budget and he's kind of
freed the teachers up and help their pay
become more of a fair shake.
Uh,
but they,
the teachers did not like that.
The majority of them,
I mean,
most people know of the huge uprising
that happened,
the protest,
hundreds of thousands of people at death
threats to every Republican in the state
legislature and the governor.
Um,
and so the teachers would leave school,
um,
they protested and they'd take leave.
They would cry in class.
I mean,
it was,
it was pretty insane.
Yeah.
And then,
you know,
you have me over here bold little
Benji's going out there and saying,
Ooh,
Rah Rah Scott Walker.
They did not like that at all.
So they would say pretty disparaging
things to be in class in front of my,
like what kinds of things would they say
to you?
My family for being business owners and
saying that they were lazy and saying
that.
Right.
Yeah.
They assume that my parents golf every
Friday,
by the way.
My parents don't know how to golf,
so that's not true.
I don't even know how to golf.
And um,
so that was,
that was one thing that they are,
that they would always say and um,
they would call me a racist or weird for
being in politics at such a young age.
What's that like for,
for a kid of that age to be dealing with
that?
It's one thing to be outspoken,
but right now your teacher is,
your authority figures are attacking you
publicly in school.
I can't imagine right
then me because at first I was pretty
taken aback and I was kind of sad about
it.
Uh,
but my parents really pushed me on and
said,
you're doing the right thing and just
kind of block out as the,
as the millennials say blackout the
haters.
Yeah.
Um,
so I didn't really care that much as
long as it didn't affect my grades,
um,
or how my classmates viewed me cause I
do care about the people that I am
friends with.
So,
uh,
so that was kind of frustrating but
after awhile it just kind of got used to
it because it would happen in a class
every single quarter of every single
semester of every single year from
seventh grade until till I started
coming out nationally about this issue.
Did it ever affect your grades?
Cause I could see a teacher in a
subjective class,
maybe not math where it would be tough
to screw with your grades,
but as a social studies teacher where
you're writing an essay or an English
teacher or something actually harming
your grade,
it did actually.
Um,
my lowest grade ever was in a social
studies class in middle school.
Uh,
I've never gotten anything really below
like a high b level.
And there I got a s a d plus and wow.
And that social studies class,
it's middle school.
So at that point it was middle school.
So it didn't really matter,
um,
per se.
But you could say,
you can see that there is a trend going
and that I'd be worried in future years
whether or not that it would affect me.
And in other classes I don't think it
did as much,
which is good.
But in that class I did see,
I mean it's a pretty obvious correlation
between me getting good grades in every
class since that and every class before
then and then getting a d plus in that
class,
which was kind of weird.
Yeah.
And also probably not a coincidence that
social studies is the class that you
were probably talking about this right
the most.
Right.
Did you,
did you try to fight the teacher on
that?
Did your folks get involved or anything?
Oh,
we actually,
I actually ended up switching schools.
Wow.
I mean,
it's incredible.
Yeah.
So,
so that was,
that was a big change.
I'd actually ended up being for the
better because,
uh,
the school I switched to is the one,
the feeder school to the high school
that I was going to.
So I ended up making better connections
there.
But,
uh,
it was an annoying change that shouldn't
have been necessary.
Um,
and it was a teacher who had a history
of these types of behaviors,
not just on politics but on other
things.
So,
um,
so it's interesting because you were
fighting the unions,
which in your estimation was actually
pro teacher because you felt the unions
were too powerful and meanwhile you have
teachers fighting you,
which is really only feeding your
initial premise right in the first
place.
Yeah.
So that was real,
it really enhanced my opinion on the
subject.
It made me really want to,
to push further because I could tell
that some of these teachers were really
worried about their job or their job
security because they knew that they
could actually be held accountable now.
And some of the senior teachers knew
that,
oh,
I actually have to perform well to get
paid well,
I don't am my age isn't just the
deciding factor.
Yeah.
So I think that that's why people came
out so strongly in certain areas.
So some people just didn't really
understand the full scope of the
situation and calm him down once they
figured that out.
But,
so I think we're really worried about
their,
their future pay because they had kind
of just been relaxed for the last 20
years since their pay had gone up.
Right.
So basically they weren't doing a great
job.
Right.
This isn't just unique to Wisconsin.
This is happening all over America where
you have these teachers that have been
at it forever.
I've kind of given up or not working
that hard anymore,
but they're protected by the unions.
Their salaries keep going up,
they get great benefits,
etc.
Etc.
That's what you're fighting and you're
seeing the fruits of what happens with
that as they're cracking down on you.
So what actually put you on,
what was the specific incident that,
that put this all in motion.
Yeah.
So I kind of took all the information
that I had of all the experiences that I
had gone through and wrote it up in a
blog for freedom works.
Um,
it ended up going to drudge and then,
um,
todd starnes at Fox wrote something up
about it.
Town hall had something.
It started to get in that space and then
eventually Megan Kelly's show reached
out,
uh,
to ask me to come on and talk about it.
So that kind of put me on the map there.
And then I started to be invited to
conferences to speak about my experience
and kind of how other young
conservatives shouldn't be scared to
speak out in the classroom even if their
teachers or other fellow students come
after them.
Um,
it wasn't easy because it was my
sophomore year of high school,
actually my fresh end of my freshman
year of high school.
And the,
after that Fox News interview,
I received death threats.
People were threatening me at school
because some of the teachers that I had
called out,
which I'd never named their names,
but I called them out.
Um,
they were popular with the students.
so people weren't happy about it.
So it was,
it was not an easy time for my family
either.
Yeah.
I want to focus on that a little bit.
Cause I think cause everyone gets this
these days.
I mean this is one of the themes.
What we do here is everyone's just like
afraid to say anything because they
don't want to deal.
They don't want to deal with just the
hate they get on twitter.
And you've got plenty of that.
And that's how I found you after this.
But,
but the other stuff,
like you had to go to school the next
day.
So literally what,
what is that like?
Well,
I,
I don't know if I've ever said this
publicly,
but I carry a knife to school cause I
was so scared,
uh,
with my life.
And I didn't tell my parents.
I had a friend give it to me that was
worried about my safety.
Um,
it was a pretty hard time,
uh,
because no matter if people think I was
doing something right or wrong,
I think part of the problem with our
culture,
and it was the same way four years ago
or five years ago,
is that if someone's doing something
that you don't agree with,
you're just going to completely attack
them wholeheartedly without any,
uh,
respect for what they're doing or their
opinions or anything like that.
And so I was honestly scared for my
life.
You know,
I couldn't go anywhere.
I got my bike stolen when I biked to an
ice cream shop and I live in a very safe
place and it was somebody from my high
school that just really didn't like me.
Yeah.
You know,
I'd be walking my dogs and some would
flip me off and say,
after you Benji backer,
you know,
suck a whatever.
What about your family at that time?
Cause I know you said your folks were
always backing you and telling you what
to do,
what you believe in.
Was there any repercussions for them or
their business or anything like that?
No,
a,
their business was fine.
I think,
you know,
most,
most adults who knew what was going on,
treating me with a lot of respect.
I think it was mostly the young people
who,
who were a little bit ignorant about
what was going on.
Um,
so my parents didn't have any negative
repercussions that I know of.
Again,
I might've been not telling me because
they didn't want to make it any worse
for me cause I got all that I care about
them.
So that was,
that was a tough time for them though,
because they live through their kids and
having something like that be constantly
going after,
uh,
are people constantly going after your
son is not the greatest thing in the
world,
especially when they know that what
you're doing is right.
So they were kind of my biggest
supporters at the time telling me to
keep pushing on and um,
you know,
again,
block out the haters and just kind of,
and do what you think is right because
at the end of the day,
people are gonna realize it eventually.
Um,
and I had tons of people come after or
come up to me a years afterwards and
apologize,
um,
and realize that what they did was
immature.
Um,
people who said the worst things to me
or told me to kill myself or whatever,
those people would come up to me and
say,
I'm really sorry.
Um,
because as people mature,
they start to realize that that's not
okay dialogue even if you totally
disagree with someone.
So
yeah,
sadly we have a lot of people who don't
mature these days.
But that is nice to hear though.
What about the support you got from your
friends?
I mean,
where your,
where your friends that supported you
willing to publicly support you because
that's enough.
See that's another,
there's,
there's certain things.
That's why I think this is so
interesting.
There are certain trends with all of
these,
whether it's you taking an unpopular but
principal position or it's a guy like
Bret Weinstein at Evergreen,
right?
Just all these different people that
come out come out.
I mean,
it's a coming out in a way that the same
tactics happen every time.
And in this case,
the idea that you're your friends or
whatever won't back you publicly,
but privately probably had no problem
doing it.
Yeah.
I had friends who
came up to me or text me saying,
I support you and I feel terrible for
what you're going through,
but I can't associate myself with you.
Um,
and those friends ended up trying to
associate it with me later on.
In a way though,
those are the worst ones,
right.
Cause it's like if someone just tells me
to go after yourself,
it's like big deal.
Okay.
Whatever.
But the friends,
it's like,
am I your shield?
You know what it'd be like?
Am I the guy that's supposed to just be
out there while you sit quietly and do
nothing?
You're not helping me.
Right.
Yeah.
I had one really good friend named
Brandon who supported me through it all.
Um,
and would come over every,
eh,
this death threat stuff started to
happen right as summer started.
Um,
which was the worst time is in high
school as a freshman,
you're not really doing anything during
the summer,
so you're just like at home sitting,
looking at your twitter thing.
Oh,
all these people want to kill me,
or they think I'm the worst person in
the world.
So it's really nice to have,
you know,
one friend who I could rely on.
Um,
plus my family.
Yeah.
And I actually took a little bit of a
break from the town that I lived in.
Um,
my dad even said,
you know,
things got worse that we could move,
um,
if that was necessary,
which I never thought it was going to be
necessary and it never was.
Um,
but I took a little bit of a break and
went to my grandparents' house for
awhile just to get away from it all.
Um,
because there was one time actually at
my house when,
well,
the two times,
once when someone called and said they
were going to come to my house and kill
me,
I had an anonymous line to my home
phone.
And then a second time when,
um,
I was watching a movie,
and it's actually Ted and I was trying
to like have a fun night after all this
stuff had been going on.
And the uh,
uh,
someone knocked on the window and was
like flipping me off and it was like in
the middle of the night is I was sitting
in my living room.
So I was pretty scared to be at home for
a little while.
And so I went away for a little bit.
Yeah.
And it's interesting cause I don't want
to Belabor the point with you and
there's a lot of other rice,
the important stuff I want to talk
about,
but I think that it's worth mentioning
just because so many people go through
this and more importantly,
you're on the other side now you made
it,
you're doing cool stuff and you survived
and it's just worth showing people that
yeah,
most usually you will survive.
Yeah.
And I think,
you know,
what was really big for me is that it
takes a strong person to go through
that.
But there are tons of people going
through the exact same thing nationwide.
And I wouldn't even say that there are
some people on the left side,
he'd go through the exact same thing
because it's not just,
it's not just people on the left who
have this nasty attitude.
It's people on the right as well.
And I think it's,
it's sickening,
um,
because even if you disagree with
someone wholeheartedly,
um,
just stay quiet if you really,
if you really are going to be that rude
and that upset about it,
be respectful and be quiet.
That's kind of how I would like to do
things.
And so I think to other people who are
in similar situations persevering
through this is the best thing that you
can go through.
I mean,
I,
I feel like I matured into a 45 or 50
year old,
but I was like 14 or 15 years old.
And so I was able to really progress in.
Um,
I think it actually might be one of the
best experiences of my life,
even though it was the one of the worst
experiences of my life in terms of
furthering myself.
It was one of the best.
And I also think,
um,
just knowing that if I can persevere
through it,
anyone can and anyone should,
and standing up for your viewpoints
isn't going to be easy,
but it's totally worth it.
Well said.
You know,
I think we talked about this while we
had lunch a couple of weeks ago.
Yeah.
And I think we talked about this,
but I told you that I think my best
professional moment is also my worst
professional moment.
And it was when Larry elder just
bludging be over the head with facts and
it was my worst because I wasn't
prepared and it was my best because it
opened me up and then I was like,
oh,
new information,
new facts.
So let's,
let's explore that.
So,
uh,
so yeah,
getting through something is pretty
beautiful.
Not that I'm comparing that moment with
Larry to everything that you,
yeah.
And I think what I've found is that it
actually,
what I did open up the eyes of a lot of
the people who attacked me,
right.
They event eventually apologized and if
they went to attack me and apologized,
they went to open their minds either,
you know,
a couple of years later they're probably
thinking back like,
Oh wow,
you know,
that was really terrible of me.
But would they ever have thought about
that?
If that wouldn't have happened,
they might've done the same thing five
years later,
which would be way worse than doing it
in high school.
So I think that going through those
experiences,
no matter what side you're on,
is better.
And I don't think that it should happen,
but it does.
It does help you persevere.
Yeah.
So that moment puts you on the map.
Now,
you know,
I started following you on twitter.
Every,
all these people are following you.
You're suddenly,
your voice is being heard,
uh,
where you immediately involved in more
activism after that or I,
cause then it's,
you had an interesting phase of like
sort of,
I could tell you were like very
frustrated with politics at times and
you were pissed at your own side a lot
and,
and you know,
and trump and all of that flashing
forward a little bit later.
But what we,
yeah,
what was the next step?
Let's just get us to,
to where you're at now.
Yeah.
I dealt with so much negative,
uh,
political,
experiences that,
so many negative political experiences
that I wanted to do something positive.
Um,
and I was sick of the partisan bickering
on both sides.
You know,
I've,
I have not really changed any of my
beliefs.
I think both sides have just gone
further and further away from the
middle,
which is frustrating.
Um,
so I actually took a year hiatus in high
school,
uh,
my senior year just to enjoy school and
enjoy my friends and kind of graduate
with,
uh,
with a fun last experience.
But I couldn't really stay away as long
as I had hoped.
I was thinking that I could probably
stay away through college as well.
Um,
but I had seen so many negative things
that there needed to be something done
that was positive and I was so,
you know,
again,
it's like get the partisan bickering
that I wanted to,
to get involved in something that would
benefit society and have a decent
dialogue,
um,
and wouldn't generate complete hate from
both sides.
And I think that we need more of that in
politics,
a decent dialogue.
And if it has to,
has to happen on an easy intro,
a issue like the environment,
which is what I focus on then so be it.
But I would hope that that could over to
really hotly contested issues too,
like gun control or immigration.
Right.
Um,
by the way,
I,
I would argue that actually talking
about the environment can be perhaps the
most hotly contested anytime,
anytime I've done anything on climate on
this show,
the amount of hate is bananas on both
sides.
Right?
So each,
of course it shouldn't be right.
We're all,
we are all living on this planet earth
through,
so we probably all care about it.
At least I hope or,
yeah,
the vast majority of us,
it's a matter of what you think is the
best way to care about it,
but we're,
okay,
so we're going to get all your,
you're working on that and just not
should be about is how we all care about
it,
but let's talk about the different
solutions.
Yeah.
Okay.
So before we get to the solutions and
what you're doing now.
Yeah.
What else?
I think when people see a young
conservative,
they,
there's still a piece of them that they
don't know what to make sense of that.
How would you describe conservatism in
2018 you gave me a little bit of sort of
what your initial thoughts on it were
when you were 10 but right now,
what do you make of just sort of the
state of conservatism?
I think that it's a pretty tough spot.
I think that what we've done as a
movement is just gone to everything
that's anti-left and I don't think that
that's how it should be.
And I don't think that it's
conservative.
I think a lot of the principles,
um,
I could go issue by issue,
but there are,
there are a lot of principals that I
don't think are necessarily conservative
and are being pushed forward now.
Like I think that there are some things
that Ronald Reagan wouldn't support in
today's time.
And I actually don't think that he'd be
successful as a conservative in today's
world.
I think people would see him as to
moderate too wishy washy when actually
he's,
he's the token conservative.
Right.
And I think that that is frustrating and
I think on the environment and every
other issue,
the conservative goals to be Anti
Hillary,
anti Bernie anti-left and sometimes we
forget to do our own solution and
sometimes we just go to the exact
opposite under the spectrum,
which is just as dangerous as whatever
the far left is proposing.
Yeah.
So I think that that's worth
conservatism is now,
and I think that is dangerous because if
it keeps going down that path,
I think the first party to start
realizing that they're just going
further and further away from the truth.
And the middle,
um,
are the first one to realize that and
change the course is going to have a lot
of success.
And I hope that conservatives can
realize that and start to come back to
what conservatism truly is,
which is free markets,
limited government.
Um,
it's not just bashing the left,
it's trying to work with them if you
can.
Um,
and it's not always a far right policy
that's going to be the answer.
And I think that what conservatism was
in 2008 or 2012,
um,
isn't exactly ideal,
but it's more,
it's closer to where,
where it should be than it is today.
Um,
and I'm not saying trump's to blame,
I think it's just a huge movement that
has been sick of the laugh for so long
and sick of the radicalism of the left
that they've done the exact same.
And I think if we could just actually
stay true to our morals and take the
higher ground,
I think that it would be a lot better
for the country.
Yeah.
It's interesting the way you described
that,
that whichever one stops first.
Yeah.
Because in my view,
and it's funny,
we come at this from different places,
right?
Like I was a card carrying lefty,
progressive liberal.
I'm obviously a little older than you,
but you came at it from,
from the other side.
And it's like,
for me,
the stuff that I focus on,
I've just seen the left implode.
Yep.
And if anything,
I would say it's basically like a train
that the brakes are off,
they know the cliff is coming,
but they're just going to keep going and
going and going and keep pouring call on
it.
And let's go off the cliff and see what
happens.
Yeah.
Don't mention Colton.
Prayer.
Yeah,
exactly.
But,
but to me that's what I've seen there.
And I really spend a lot of my life,
at least these last couple years trying
to correct that.
Okay.
What I do see,
and I think maybe,
maybe you agree,
but maybe not as,
I do see more fertile ground on the
right for ideas that I can now go to
libertarian events and conservative
events and they hear my differences and
they're willing to hear them out.
Where I see virtually none of that on
the left.
Do you think that's a fair estimation
even though I know you were concerned
obviously about what's happening on the,
on the fringes of the right?
I do to a certain degree.
I can't,
there is more,
and I think it's a relative statement.
I don't think that it's,
it's enough.
No,
I don't think it's nowhere,
anywhere near enough.
Um,
I think the perfect example is that any
conservative that doesn't agree with
trump 100% of the time it's kind of
shunned and you look at an amount like
Seapak or how the rnc looks at things or
something like that.
And I think that what they should be
doing is embracing people of all
ideologies that come from the
conservative perspective.
And I think when it comes to young
people,
not every young person is gung Ho for
trump.
Not every young person is Gung Ho for,
Oh,
uh,
you know,
a wall or whatever it may be.
And I think that conservatives need to
embrace the diversity more in a
leadership level.
I think like I college campuses,
like the College Republicans tend to be
a more open and I think even like a
county party,
it would be more open to different
views.
Obviously,
I don't know every county party and then
millions of counties that we have here.
But the,
the fact of the matter is I think that
the national landscape or at least the
national leaders are currently unlikely
to care about what no moderates think or
what even our typical conservative
things if they're not on 100% in
agreement.
Um,
and again,
I think conferences kind of show that
like the,
the Seapak conference.
Um,
and I think it,
and that's been an issue going on for
years.
I mean the log cabin Republicans were
banned from Seapak for,
I dunno,
how many years,
six years.
Um,
and I think that we just need to
diversify the party and that's going to
include non Christians.
It's going to include Lgbtq people,
it's going to include minorities and
it's,
and it,
it's going to include women and that's
going to be the future of the
Conservative Party along with the
support that we have now.
Otherwise,
we're going to be going down a very
wrong track record and if we keep
shaming all those people,
it's going to be tough.
What part of you doesn't say you're a
libertarian?
Because I think I know so much about
what your ideas are and you're trying to
build all those bridges.
I can give you a libertarian reason for
why all of those people obviously should
be included in a conservative party or
any party.
Is there anything about libertarian or
do you just not,
you're just doing a little political
realism,
which I hear from a lot of people.
It's like I'm a libertarian,
but the Conservatives and the
Republicans are the party that I can
work with most to to get those right.
I think that that's what you just said
is probably the best answer I have.
The other thing that I would say is I
think that there are,
I disagree with Libertarian sometimes on
the level of government that should be
involved.
I'm still a limited government person.
I also think of myself as like a Reagan
conservative,
but Reagan wasn't anti government and a
lot of ways he increased spending some
times he did taxes when it is necessary.
Um,
again,
I'm limited government and when spending
is not possible,
we should never,
you know,
we should ever perceive spending if it,
if it can be avoided.
Same with taxes and everything like
that.
But I also don't think that it's
completely off the table,
which some libertarians do.
Not all,
but I think that I probably issues why
is agreeing North Libertarians,
especially on social things,
um,
maybe even immigration.
Um,
but I think at some of the,
just the overarching government
involvement,
I think the government does have a place
in some things.
Um,
but it should be trying to help the
people.
Um,
instead of push things on the people,
which I think is,
is something that maybe makes me a
little bit more moderate.
You've decided to put your stop if the,
if the Republican or the right
conservative trains going off that way
and you've decided to put your stake in
the ground and say,
we're going to talk about environment.
Yup.
Now even just hashtag green gop,
I mean people think the Republicans,
the general consensus out there,
if you ask the average person walking
down the street,
Republicans either hate the environment
or the,
or they want endless pollution and they
believe in industry more than the earth.
I mean just you,
all of this stuff that really generally
I find not to be true,
but they haven't done a great job on
answers.
Yup.
So first off,
how much do you think people your age
generally care about the environment?
Yeah,
so I think,
you know,
millennials according to some recent
polling showed that that's the most
important issue.
Um,
the environment is in terms of when they
go to the voting booth.
Um,
the University of Texas and Pew Research
polls have shown that.
So I think that that's a huge wakeup
call to conservatives that this is
something that an important voter base
is interested in tackling.
Um,
I know that most conservatives are
behind clean energy,
especially when they're young.
Um,
millennials especially.
And then obviously the laughters as
well.
And so I think clean energy,
sustainability and just the general
environmental issues are very important
to young people.
And then a recent poll just came out
that showed that climate change,
uh,
57% of conservatives,
millennials want action on it,
which is a pretty big amount.
And then you've got 77% of independence
and an 84% of liberals.
So climate change is also a very
important issue to millennials.
So I think that all those together to
kind of showcase why it's important that
conservative starts to talk about these
issues.
Yeah.
How would you have this new thing is
about belief,
whether people actually believe the
science on this,
of whether manmade climate change is
real versus just what the answers are.
So I know you were focusing on the
answers,
which I want to get into,
but that basically,
meaning it's either you have some set of
people that believe or don't believe,
but then you have this other subset of
people that either think the government
is the answer or that the private sector
is the answer.
How do you even get those things to meet
in some way?
So I think that the private sector and
limited government is the answer for
these issues and that,
or if you believe the science or don't
believe the science,
I think that we all,
like we said earlier,
can agree that these issues do matter.
That protecting the earth doesn't
matter,
no matter if climate change is real or
not,
we still have a duty to protect the land
that we've been given by God.
Um,
and so I think that that's something
that can gel with most conservatives.
And then with people on the left or even
independence,
if there are kind of convinced that big
government is the answer,
which has been kind of the only solution
proposed so far.
Right.
It's our job as conservatives to
showcase why one that doesn't work,
which is what we do focus on,
but two is
let,
let's focus on one for a minute.
Why doesn't that work?
Cause I think most people,
because most people don't think
critically about these things,
they go,
okay,
I believe in climate change.
The meme is out there.
Yup.
You believe in climate change,
they always look to the government.
So they go,
Whoa,
I believe in climate change.
What's the government doing about it as
opposed to the alternatives that you're
offering?
So first,
how do you disconnect those two things?
Well,
the first problem is that most people
have only seen that as the only answer.
So that's all the thick hand associated
with environmental progress,
which is a problem in itself.
But why they haven't worked.
Why had,
the big government hasn't worked on
these issues.
And some examples of that is the
endangered species act,
which has only taken 1% of the listings
awful list,
uh,
since 1982 and there had been a ton of
new species added.
And the reason that is,
is because private land owners don't
have any rights on their land.
If they have a endangered species that's
residing on their land,
the government can come in and take it,
control it.
Uh,
which is really frustrating to land
owners.
So what they try to do is either move it
off their land or they just shoot it and
bury it so they can keep their land,
which is again people just trying to
avoid big government from coming in and
taking their private property because
private property is one of the most
inherent rights that we have and
something that people really like to
protect.
Just pause there cause what a what a
whacked out situation that is.
So if you have some private land that
has something that's on this endangered
species list,
you might go ahead and kill it.
Yup.
So that the government won't know that
it's there so that even if you don't
want to,
you might love animals.
You might love nature.
Usually the case.
Right.
I would assume most of these people who
would probably is the case.
You might literally be killing
endangered animals just so the
government won't take your land.
That's how warp to this whole thing is.
Yeah.
And the uh,
the mantra is,
shoot,
Barry shut up.
That is a common thread when it comes to
endangered species.
A and kind of how private land owners
look at it,
which is really sad because like you
said,
most of them do care about animals.
They,
they have farms and they just have
private property and they love nature.
Why they have a place in nature.
They don't want to shoot these places,
but they also don't,
or these animals,
but they also don't want to give up
their land and have it controlled by the
government,
uh,
until,
until whatever date they deem fit.
Um,
and that would be really frustrating as
a private land owner who worked hard and
purchase the land.
It's just not a good way to approach it.
And that is the same problem that we've
had with tons of other issues is that
when there's big government involved,
there's always a loophole to get around
it.
There's always a loophole to get around
the punishment.
And usually that loophole hurts the
environment is people don't respond
well.
The punishments,
they respond well to incentives.
They respond well to doing things on
their own for moral good or economic,
a wellbeing.
And so I think that's where the policies
need to shift.
And then another example of the big
government not working is the Paris
climate accords,
right?
It would be,
in theory,
having every country come together to
try to help the environment is a great
idea,
right?
That that just sounds nice and peachy of
course.
Sounds good.
Okay.
But then when you're making the people
who aren't polluting pay for it and the
people who are polluting go off scotch
free and no countries are meeting their
goals and there's just a ton of money
being thrown around that's going to no
benefit or it has no benefit on the
environment and it's non binding.
There was nonbinding,
there was literally no mechanism to
force anyone to do anything.
So the u s could do the bulk of the
payments,
but we don't have any mechanism to check
whether anyone's doing anything.
Right.
And we're doing those things in terms of
cutting emissions on her own.
It's technology,
it's innovation,
it's hybrid cars,
which the left loves to paint.
But where did it come from?
The free market.
Where's the electric cars come from?
Where has Microsoft,
we're having Microsoft and apple and all
these companies who have started to cut
their emissions.
They're doing it because of the market.
They're doing it.
Not because the government is telling
them to not be as the Paris climate
accords are telling them to,
but because they know it's the right
thing to do.
The sensible thing to do.
I on an economic level and even oil and
gas companies are cleaning up their acts
because they know it's necessary for pr,
but they also know that being more
environmentally sustainable,
it's going to be better in the long run
economically.
So it's not going to be some huge accord
that changes these things,
especially when they're not pressuring
the right countries like China to
actually act and do something about it.
It's going to be countries deciding on
their own level what's going to be right
and how they're going to fix it.
And if countries want to come together
and create an actually cohesive plan
that works and gets things done and give
some flexibility and doesn't,
um,
just do nothing,
then that's great.
That should be something that happens
and something that president trump
should actually encourage a beneficial
accords.
The Paris climate accords doesn't do
that.
And that's an example of big government
failing.
I like that you're linking this directly
to technology because it also,
it's sorta like,
you know,
20 years ago if there was an oil spill
somewhere in some remote area of
Antarctica,
most likely we wouldn't have heard about
it.
You know,
unless
it was a massive one like that.
Cause I'm about these or something.
But like a lot you could get away with a
lot.
But these days literally everyone in the
Western world at least has a cell phone,
right worker is at these places.
If there's a leak,
can videotape it anonymously,
upload it to twitter and then everyone
finds out.
So it's so obvious to me that technology
is the answer here.
The,
you know,
cause everyone's always afraid if you
get rid of any of these lines is what I
hear from,
from the left all the time.
I've been here this from,
from bill models and if you,
if you get rid of these laws,
they are going to start polluting the
lake,
right,
right next to the,
to the factory.
And it's like,
nope,
actually no,
not anymore.
Oh,
accountable.
And that's just the truth.
And some of that I'd love to point out
is that technology is the reason why
emissions those have started to go down.
Technology is the reason why we have so
many amazing opportunities to fix the
environment.
There's no big government regulation
that's able to cut emissions like
technology can.
And one thing that's really amazingly
pointed out by one of our board members,
Todd Myers,
is that thing about how much the iphone
itself can do and conservation and
climate.
You are able to control your heating and
energy costs from your phone,
turn off the energy when you don't use
it and control it completely from your
phone instead of having to run back to
your house before you go on a long
vacation or whatever.
And then just saying,
okay,
a screw it,
I'll just leave them on my lights or
whenever it is.
Yeah.
That's helping the environment a ton and
each year more,
uh,
effective cars come out with more miles
per the gallon or electric and hybrid or
electric is starting to really start to
take over,
which is really exciting.
That's technology that's not the
government and technology and
environmental progress go hand in hand
and you look at oil spills or you look
at nuclear waste or whatever.
All those have improved dramatically
over the past couple of decades because
these companies know that that has to
happen.
People will find out about it and never
give them business again and basically
shut down their business if,
if more accidents start to happen.
I mean,
look at what bp went through.
BP is one of the best stewards on the
environment out of gas companies ever
since then because they know that they
can't have that type of a situation
again.
Yeah,
they can't have like how many days was
that thing leaking and there was the
live camera on.
Right.
Everyone knew about it.
I mean if she has any American they
would know about the BP oil spill.
Where do you guys stand on nuclear?
Just a couple of weeks ago,
I had Mike Shellenberger in here who
love my shown.
Oh,
okay,
cool.
So this is interesting then.
So you are a conservative with some
libertarian leanings.
Yeah,
he's running for governor of California
as a Democrat.
You know,
he started as an independent,
but I think just for,
because of a little political realism,
he's running as a Democrat,
but obviously for nuclear power and he's
trying to erase some of the stigma to
it,
which there's obviously a tremendous
amount,
you know,
just unnecessary.
Fukushima was just a couple of years
ago.
Right.
So,
so that's interesting.
So you like this guy.
Yeah.
Michael Shellenberger is a perfect
example of what democrats need to aspire
to be and that is common sense.
Able to work with sides isn't afraid to
just stray away from the talking points
of the laughed,
which is,
which are usually incorrect,
especially on like nuclear.
Nuclear is supposed to be the most
dangerous and harmful when in reality
it's kind of the future.
And Michael Shellenberger knows that.
So,
uh,
Michael Shellenberger is great and I
think that California would be much
improved by having a governor as
moderate as him.
Yeah.
You know,
we're going to get me Gavin newsome.
Right?
But what can you do proper?
Michael should,
I may have to move to Wisconsin.
I think it's got water is great and I
think he'll be there for another four
years,
hopefully after this year.
Um,
but yeah,
I think nuclear is,
is an important part of an all of the
above energy strategy that America needs
to start adopting.
And nuclear is the least amount of
accidents out of any energy sector.
They're really improving a technology.
I mean,
if there's only been like three nuclear
accidents in history,
everyone knows about them because
they're terrible.
But there haven't been any since Japan
and,
and all of them are avoidable.
All of them are avoidable.
None of them have happened in the United
States because the United States has
been careful about it.
And these companies are careful and it's
almost become impossible with recent
technology to have an accident like
that.
Unless you were like deliberately trying
to hurt the area around you and trying
to,
to release the waste.
Is it partly because of government
regulation that our nuclear plants
haven't had problems that keep,
can you give any credit in that way?
Uh,
I,
I don't know enough about how those
regulations have worked,
but all I know is that regulations from
the government have shut down nuclear
progress,
uh,
because right now they're discouraging.
Nuclear plants are being built and not
our,
I don't think any are being built
currently.
Uh,
because the United States government is
trying to phase it out when really it's
going to,
it's clean,
it's effective,
it cuts and missions and it's very
powerful.
Um,
and I know that I think the vast
majority of the changes have come from
these companies realizing that there's
no way for them to succeed if they
aren't careful with their operations.
And they also know that,
I mean,
unless you're a terrible human being,
you don't want to put nuclear waste and
you don't want to give everyone cancer
and have them die unless you're a
terrible human being.
So I think that that's also just part of
a thing.
And,
and,
and new technology is,
is making nuclear more effective and
less dangerous.
And I,
and I,
I think it's safe to say that nuclear is
almost a hundred percent foolproof at
this point in time.
But you can't always go on the best
intention to these people cause,
right.
Yes.
I agree.
Most people don't want people that have
cancer and do all that stuff.
But you know,
business owners,
just like government regulators often do
shady things.
So it's part of the issue here is that
you can't always control the business
owner.
Yup.
The industrialist.
But you also can't always control the
government.
So there,
there isn't a perfect answer here,
right?
Yeah.
No there's not.
And I think that there are,
it is the duty of the government to
protect the people to a certain degree.
I mean,
you're not it.
They have to band murder and they have
to ban certain things.
So not,
uh,
so that's not lawful.
And I think that certain basic
protections can be put in place on
nuclear to make sure that these
companies are making sure that it's
safe.
They shouldn't be so stringent that you
can't start one up or that you get
punished for,
um,
you know,
what x,
Y or z unless it's a terrible breach of,
of uh,
knowledge.
So I think that that's something that
the government can play into.
I think it's going to be more up to the
technology and the business owners to
have the answers to make nuclear better
with a couple basic nuclear,
uh,
government regulations.
What kind of traction are you guys
getting sorta with mainstream
Republicans and with people that are in
office right now because these seem to
be the answers that I would love these
guys to take a,
but they've been very hesitant to take.
Yeah.
So one thing before we even launched
this organization,
I met with a lot of congressmen and
women and the on the Republican side and
they said that they cared about these
issues.
They wanted to tackle them,
but the only reason I didn't was because
they didn't hear from their base.
They only heard it from the Sierra Club
and the League of conservation voters.
And the fact of the matter is those
people are never going to be their
voters and matter how they come out on
environmental issues.
So we think that there is a latent base
of support not only at the base but with
legislators who want to lead on these
issues,
but they just need some uh,
pushing.
Um,
so I think that that's something that
the conservative movement is ready for
and there are a good handful of 20 to 25
current Republican congressmen and women
who are already leading on these issues.
It's just a matter of getting that
number up and starting to have those
legislators hear from their base,
talking about the base.
The base is totally ready,
especially millennials,
like I was talking about earlier with
some of the polling that's been done.
Basically all young conservatives care
about the environment in one way or the
other.
No matter if it's climate change related
or not,
they're ready for clean energy.
They're ready for all of the above
energy.
They're ready for common sense
conservation practices.
And so we have had such success with the
base that we have 37 out of 50 college
Republicans,
state chairs on board with what we're
doing.
I was more to come in the next few
months.
We are working with countless college
Republican and turning point USA and
young Americans for freedom chapters
across the country to spread some of
these things.
We have the support of all the youth
leaders on the right.
Charlie Kirk Chandler,
Thorton of the College Republicans,
grants Strobel as young Americans for
freedom.
Um,
it's really been welcoming and we hadn't
really gotten too much flak from the
right because they're so ready for
something like this with common sense
solutions.
It's interesting.
Does this feel like a little bit of a
perfect storm right now for you guys
with what's going on on college
campuses?
I mean,
you know,
I had charlie in here from turning point
a couple of weeks ago and I did.
The guy is just knocking it out of the
park it every day what they're doing.
Yeah.
It's just incredible to me.
Even for the things that I disagree with
them on.
Yep.
It's like you've really built this grass
root thing.
I was just at the students for liberty
conference a couple of weeks ago.
I thought what they were doing is great.
I think what you're doing is great that
suddenly it seems like there's this like
backlash against the hysteria of the
left than what you would say is also the
the history or at least in environmental
terms,
the backward thinking of the right that
it's kind of led to a nice moment here
where,
Whoa,
maybe there are some other answers.
Yeah,
and I think college students are so sick
of being painted as anti environment and
they don't really know where to amp that
with.
The answer is and concern us haven't
really provided the answer.
They just go on and go after the last,
which is great.
We need to criticize the left on their
environmental policies that haven't
worked,
but we also have to provide our own
answers and I think you're,
you hit on something perfectly in that
college.
Students are always looking for more
knowledge and uh,
to be more active and issues that they
care about.
Turning Point USA has done that ton of,
a ton of other organizations have begun
to really activate young people.
And the environment is something that's
been kind of left out so far.
And that's why turning point in College
Republicans are so supportive is because
they realize that that's an important
part of their mission is to garner
attention and activism from people that
may really care about the environment
and maybe a little bit hesitant to be
active unless the conservatives are more
active on that issue.
So I think that is a perfect storm and
there's no other group like us out
there.
There's no group advocating for
conservative environmental solutions.
We're doing it,
focusing on millennials,
but there's nobody doing it for any age
group.
And so we're having to work with
anybody.
But,
uh,
I think that it's perfect.
And then also,
uh,
conservatives are looking for a way to
talk to liberals on some issues on
college campuses.
College campuses are so divided that,
you know,
you bring in a speaker,
even if they're the most moderate
speaker and there's protests,
you know,
up the Wazoo,
there's,
there's no,
there's no end to it.
Even if you bring in John Case that
you're going to get half,
you know,
half of your school out there protesting
saying he's a white nationalist.
Right,
right.
So even though most people would say the
navy,
he identifies more with the Democratic
Party now.
So I think sometimes they do it when
that day Reuben guy shows up.
It's very busy.
It's crazy though.
He's off the walkies off the diva.
I understand that one.
But yeah.
Uh,
but I think,
you know,
if we can have a dialogue with people on
the left and showcase that we actually
do care about the environment,
we're just not,
we're not anti left on everything.
We just want to work with you guys on
the actual common sense solutions,
not what you guys are pushing but
something that maybe both sides can
agree on.
What I have found in my own college
campus,
cause I go to the University of
Washington in Seattle,
is that I've talked to a bunch of
typical people who would show up to a
protest,
maybe even mtf up and they've found
that,
okay,
let's just kind of fun.
There's a conservative who cares about
the environment.
That's cool.
I didn't know they existed.
And I'm like,
well they're everywhere.
Almost every conservative that you've
ever talked to or protested against
cares about the environment.
But we need to start having that
dialogue.
And I think that slowly it can sort of
start to bring together some of the
divide on call.
I would imagine that in a place like
University of Washington,
they look,
you got Seattle there.
That's obviously progressive Palooza.
But I would imagine there's so many
people there that lives suburban lives
and out there in nature and all of those
things where they had this strange
dichotomy.
Now they've been told that the
Republicans hate the environment,
they love the environment,
but they also love freedom because they
want to be on their own land.
All that.
So to me that's a very fertile ground.
It's a just the,
I would imagine that the Pacific
northwest is probably the perfect place
to start using this as the incubator
it is.
And some of the old conservative leaders
in Washington state,
we're pioneers for environmental
progress nationally.
You've got former governor Dan Evans who
created the Department of the ecology,
which was what was,
uh,
the EPA was founded after,
which is supposed to be a limited
government but important agency that
only stepped in when necessary.
It's gone far past those bounds.
But that's what he had done.
And he was a conservative.
A lot of the public land has been named
after him because of all of his
contribution to conservation in the
state.
You've got a lot of former senators and
congressmen and women,
even some current ones who are leading
on these issues from the Republican side
because they realize they live on this
land there in the mountains there,
yeah.
In the cascades and the Olympics and
they really care.
Um,
and I think that it's a different state
for that.
And then if you take away a Seattle,
it's a very conservative state.
I mean,
you can say that about a lot of states,
but uh,
and their big cities,
but in Washington,
a lot of those mountainous,
rural areas that are constantly impacted
by the environment or they live in the
environment,
uh,
itself are conservative people who want
to have leadership on this issue,
but just don't really know where to find
it and only know,
like you said,
of the big government,
um,
interactions that can happen.
And you've got the Seattle mayor and
the,
and the Washington governor who claim to
care about the environment,
but nothing ever happens.
And I think a lot of people are sick of
those things,
especially in a state like Washington
where the environment matters.
Yeah.
So where are you at with trump on all
this?
Because,
okay,
we talked about climate,
the Paris climate accords.
He got us out of that.
So I sent your,
you're happy about that.
His regulation situation,
I think they're cutting something and it
changes all the time,
but if they're cutting a ton of
regulation for every new one that they
pass,
I think you're generally for that.
But I know you're not a big trump guy.
That's probably putting it mildly,
right?
Yes.
So where,
where do you think he falls on the
environmental stuff?
I think I actually haven't been as
annoyed with his environmental policies
as I would have thought before he was
elected or even right after he was
elected,
which I think is a good thing.
But I think part of the problem that he
falls into,
which is what most conservatives fall
into,
is that they criticize the laugh.
They might like deregulate,
they might remove some protections or
whatever,
but what are they going to do as an
answer?
What's going to be their solution that
isn't anti-left or that,
you know,
whatever.
Whatever the solution is that they're
cutting.
What are they going to replace that
with?
And I think that trump hasn't done a
good enough job,
just like most conservatives recently of
doing that.
Um,
swap of policy in terms of if you're
going to remove the protection here,
how are you going to protect it on the,
Yep.
So what is that answer that you'd like?
Well,
I would like to see a and all of the
above energy policy that is not focused
on um,
subsidies or tax breaks.
We need to remove those from the clean
energy or just from the energy sector in
general.
I was actually not a fan of,
of trump's tariff on solar because while
they have a ton of tax breaks,
so does oil and coal and we need to just
put them on an even level playing field
because consumers care about the free
market.
Also have the free market compete and if
soar is the worst thing in the world and
it's just being propped up by subsidies,
let's have the free market take it out.
If the coal,
if calls done,
let's have colgate taken out.
The free market needs to just dominate
on the energy sector.
And I think that the president needs to
focus on that.
Where would you leave a lot of that to
the state?
So for example,
a place like California where the sun is
shining,
you know,
367 days a year,
uh,
you'd be for California just doing
whatever it feels is right and related
to solar.
Exactly.
I think it should be up to the states
and their different states that need
different things,
right?
Like Iowa and different states in the
Midwest get a lot of wins.
So,
so,
uh,
you know,
when energy makes a ton of sense.
Um,
there are states like Washington that
have a lot of water and hydropower makes
a lot of sense.
Arizona and Texas are two of the leading
states on solar.
They're conservative states and usually
solar is identified as a liberal thing,
but those governors have totally
implemented solar rvs.
They know it works and they know it's
effective in their states.
Solar would not really work that well in
Seattle.
Right.
So it just depends on the state.
And I think that unless the free market
can decide that and have different
states figure out what they need,
uh,
it's going to be really frustrating
because it's,
again,
it's going to be really frustrating for
states like Texas and Arizona and
California who now are going to have to
pay a premium for solar when it's been
really effective there.
And now there's a tariff on it and an
unnecessary tariff.
And then,
you know,
what,
what are they gonna do?
They're going to have to figure out a
different way to get their energy for
those areas that they're losing the
solar from.
So I've,
and solar panels,
it's not like the ones that are already
there can just stay there.
They have like a 10 year lifespan a lot
of the time.
So a lot of them needs to be replaced.
And if there's a new tariff that's
damaging.
So I think that it just needs to be left
up to the states.
And I think it also needs to be a lot of
deregulation,
less subsidies,
less tax breaks on the energy side.
Yeah.
So a couple of minutes ago you mentioned
that the EPA has gone well past its
mandate.
Yeah.
I think this is an interesting one to,
to sort of end on because I think it's a
good place to start when you're talking
to people because everyone,
I think if you talk to the average
person that,
that wants to do good by the
environment,
they automatically think the EPA is
good,
right?
It just environmental protection agency.
It sounds good.
How could that possibly be bad?
What does that actually mean?
That they've gone beyond their original
mandate and why does it keep growing and
growing and grow?
They're supposed to enforce the law,
not create the law.
And the EPA has gone to the point where
they are creating their own laws and
they had been incredibly,
incredibly regulatory,
um,
and have not helped the environment at
all.
What they're supposed to do is enforce
what Congress passes and what the
American people want.
And environmental protection.
For example,
some Republicans put together a really
amazing coastal barrier,
uh,
resiliency act while Reagan was
president and the EPA enforces that.
That's what the EPA is supposed to do,
not create their own regulations that
says you can't do this.
You can't do this.
Let that be up to the states and the
local areas and if it needs to happen on
the national level,
what type of a vote on it.
And I think the EPA has become more of a
punishment organization rather than a
let's help the environment and get
people to do the right thing.
Um,
and only enforce the law.
That's really what it's supposed to be.
And it's not become that at all.
Um,
that being said,
they,
they enforce the law.
So those things need to stay in place.
You can't just remove that,
but they have created their own really
unnecessary regulatory reforms that have
just not worked.
Is that just the best argument for small
government in general that we just
create these things,
these entities that are well
intentioned?
Usually?
I think usually most of them are well
at,
you know,
department of education sounds good.
We're going to educate people,
environmental protective,
we're going to predict the environment
that these are usually well intentioned.
But then just because of the way the
government works because of gridlock in
Washington,
because of all the money poured in,
they become these albatrosses that
they've pretty much never,
uh,
were intended to be.
Yeah.
I think that that kind of leads into a
bigger issue as of how do we keep that
from happening.
Because I think most people will agree
that there needs to be some sort of
government.
We're not just going to be governed by
ourselves.
We need to have some sort of government
and,
but it needs to be held accountable.
So I don't know how often they need to
look at where these agencies had been
going,
but obviously a lot of that have gone
way past what they need to be doing.
The Department of Education is a perfect
example of really actually ruining the
education system in the United States.
And EPA has gone way past what it needs
to be doing.
We need to have a way to check on these
areas frequently and make sure that
they're sticking to what they were
created to do and not going past that,
uh,
and being held accountable for it.
And I'm sure that happens.
It definitely happens with every new
administration,
but nothing really ever changes.
And I think that it's trump and every
president from here on out that needs to
analyze when they get into office,
where these agencies are at,
how we can cut down or increase if
that's necessary,
what they're doing.
And I think that that can be a really
good answer,
but a bigger answer is to have state
governments and local leaders and local
governments as well as businesses do
their own thing on these issues to prove
to the government,
the federal government,
that we don't need restrictions,
we don't need regulations,
we can do it ourselves and we're far
more effective.
And I think that that's the answer
rather than waiting on Congress to do
something.
Well that is a great closing statement,
my friend.
But I got to ask you one more because
it's so obvious to me.
You've become a master at what what you
care about and you're trying to do good
work and that you actually are affecting
people.
So what year are you running for office?
Just give me a ballpark.
Maybe 2036
wow.
Usually when I've asked a few people
this,
they pumped the question.
You did not punt for more on Benjy and
his budding political campaign.
Check them out on twitter at Benji
backer.